why don't we get started it's 9:00 a.m.
so good morning everyone
oh man I guess if you're on the East
Coast good afternoon I'm Alex very
co-director of the EB 2k centers
Coordination Center and so last week we
had a wonderful kickoff to section 2 of
our fundamentals to data science web
seminars where we're now talking about
data representation issues we had an
overview of some of the challenges that
was given by our dr. bender ASCII of the
UC San Diego
so in today's talk we're going to go a
bit deeper now into some of the key
ideas and issues in the organization of
big data focusing primarily on the
databases and repositories to be used to
manage and combine information so we'll
be giving a perspective on the evolution
of databases and how they're changing to
handle big data so it's my pleasure to
actually introduce two people who will
be speaking to us today on this topic so
our first speaker is dr. Shaitaan you
better love the National Science
Foundation dr. Peru is the senior
advisor for data science in NSF sized
directory where he coordinates the cross
foundation big data research program and
co-chairs the big data interagency
working group our second speaker is dr.
Elena Zilla Zulueta she's a computer
scientist for the background in machine
learning social network analysis and
online privacy dr. Saliba
is a science and technology policies
fellow of the American Association for
the Advancement of science at NSF where
she's involved in a number of big data
and data science initiatives doctors
maroons
is a liver we're delighted to have you
with us and so without further ado let's
get started dr. Barry yes we can all
right so I'm also assuming that you're
seeing outside so actually what we'd
like to do is this is going to be a
joint presentation between Ellen and
myself and as you heard helena is more
of the machine learning side with big
data and my background is actually more
on the data management side so it's so
he'll get started talking about some of
the interesting machine learning kinds
of things that we had that people have
been
doing now with all sorts of interesting
data that's out there and I'll try to
give a little bit more perspective on
the data management side so if you're
seeing seeing of a slur it basically
talks about you know technologies like
databases data warehouses and in this
today's talk when we talk about
databases both of our computer
scientists as you heard we'll be talking
about it more a little bit more from the
technical meaning of databases rather
than sort of any community repository so
there's a generic use of the term
database that generally men refers to
any or manage data but will be a little
bit more technical about that and then
the process will try to come cover some
of the issues of structures Python
integrations one way to think about what
we will talk about today is maybe at
least in some aspects of it maybe more
of a computer science view of some of
the issues that you heard and if they
talk about in the last presentation so
let's see if I hopefully you're seeing
our second slide so that's the two of us
and myself going further the outline so
and then I will talk about some of the
design tasks
examples now the kind of things we doing
and what we decided to do in this
presentation in one hour we want to we
have to give you a very quick tour of
all the things going on so I'm going to
take a sort of historical view of data
management where we started and where we
are and when we get there ll say why we
are trying to do that talk about some of
the current technologies and then you
know with where things are going and
some of the take home messages so let's
get started with Eleanor who's right
here hi good morning everyone so since
this is a lecture series on the
fundamentals of data science I thought
it would be helpful to give you a data
scientist perspective on why today's
topic is important in the process of
doing data science and while you don't
necessarily need to understand all the
technology details of the data
management solutions out there as a data
scientist you do need to have a good
idea of when to use once
versus another so first I will give you
some typical scenarios that they
assigned its face imagine that you are
interested in one of these three
research questions listed on this slide
for example how do new research topics
emerge how do kids use playgrounds how
can you create more secure code there
are many different approaches that you
can take to answer these questions but
given that we live in the age of big
data
I will reformulate these questions
specifically to take advantage of large
publicly available datasets so the first
question was about how new research
topics emerge Network scientists may
approach this problem by studying
citation networks more specifically
which are those reference which other
articles and how research topics
propagated through these articles over
time and as most of you know one large
data source of publication citations is
PubMed PubMed currently contains over 26
million articles and probably an order
of magnitude more reference pairs or
which articles cite which other articles
so you can see this is already a very
very problem that can be solved through
a lot of data the second research
question that I presented was one that
the behavioral scientist might be
interested in about how kids use
playgrounds and more specifically the
angle on this question that I am taking
here here is what we user-generated
videos on playgrounds tell us about how
kids use playgrounds so for example in
September this year Google released the
data set for research purposes from
YouTube which contains 8 million videos
and around 1.5 terabytes of data and
each video is actually tagged by the
entities that are included in the
different frames of the video and you
can actually search by entities so for
example if I search for playgrounds I
can find that this day
it contains 255 videos of playgrounds
that's great
255 videos is not a lot of data right
it's only 55 however for you to extract
these videos and do analysis on these
videos you need to download the full 1.5
terabytes of data and find these videos
in order to do analysis of them the
third research question that I presented
was about how to create more secure code
and it's a question that research that
security researchers might be interested
in the specific angle that we can take
on it is what you can learn from version
updates of code repositories in order to
create more secure code and as an
example here I would like to give github
github is a very popular two amongst
software developers and it currently
contains of over thirty eight million
repositories
moreover Google actually made 2.8
million of these recorders available
querying to bigquery and this is already
over 3 terabytes of data and here I'm
just giving a specific example of a few
such repositories that are related to
computational biology so all these 3
tasks actually require processing large
amounts of data and today we're not
going to talk about how we're going to
answer these questions but we will
actually talk about how we can process
such data so when you answer research
questions with data there are many
different sources of data that you may
have access to some of them may have
structured data others semi structured
data but the majority of data out there
falls in the category of unstructured
data structured data is data that has a
predefined data model such as they're in
relational databases and it is fairly
straightforward to query semi structured
data is a type of structured data where
you your schema is often contained
within the data itself and some examples
include XML and JSON files unstructured
data does not have a predefined data
model which makes them harder to query
and
examples input scientific articles where
you can have a mix of figures algorithms
and text and where each article may have
different section structures so one may
start with introduction and then related
work can then go on to algorithms and
another one may start with an
introduction and then jump into actual
data analysis so video data is another
example where the video frames do not
follow the seller predefined data model
and lastly coop repositories can have
different folders and file structures
and n types now that you know what kind
of data you're dealing with you need to
decide on where you will store the data
and how you can query to answer your
questions of interest all three tasks
that I described required to process
large amounts of data and there are many
solutions to storing and managing large
data sets that exist out there one can
easily spend a lot of time exploring and
trying to decide on the best tool to use
do use the latest tool do you stick to
using what you feel most comfortable
with and the answer is it depends some
of these tools provide a similar set of
capabilities others are complementary to
each other for example if you're a
software application developer you may
store the data that your application
collects in a my sequel database but you
may want to explore it to a Hadoop
cluster or a cloud service in order to
enable fast analytics on it you may also
want to use a Redis store for the
results from your analytics engine so
that your application has fast access to
access to your analytical results
something that plays an important role
in deciding on the best tools to use for
a specific task is the characteristics
of the data that you're dealing with you
need to take into consideration the
volume of the data its variety and
diversity whether it's streaming and at
what speed and also what you plan to use
the data for whether it's an internal
report that you need to generate once a
day or whether it is to produce
analytical data it has to be made
available for real-time and today
instead of making specific
recommendations on which tools you
should use or talking about low level
details of the technology behind them
would like to take you on a journey in
the history of databases and how the
different modern tools came to be and
why they're important so I'm going to
then switch into sort of the history
board and said be you sort of decided
that we might want to give you more of
an overview of the landscape of what's
out there so if any of your computer
science people or have been interacting
with computer scientists especially with
all the recent stuff going on with big
data and the whole focus on data you
might have heard people talking about
well so what's what's new here you know
are we doing anything different how does
it relate to what we've already been
doing so we thought maybe a perspective
on where we are coming from which
hopefully will have understand where we
are going you know so where we are today
in and where we are going
I think the the take-home message
actually have cycled that at the end but
to give you right up front is we are now
in a situation where there are a lot of
choices available to us that's good and
bad I mean it's bad in the sense that
that means you have to understand what
your choices are and make the right
decisions but it's good in the sense
that depending on the kind of problem
you are tackling like you had three
different examples you could actually
choose different solution methods and
again as I'll say at the end then some
of it may depend on how much freedom you
have you know how you're doing it for
yourself or you in the corporate context
where you don't have you know maybe you
don't have as much control but anyway
let's launch into this one more thing I
wanted to say before getting a starting
is I didn't I didn't actually introduce
spend a minute introducing ourselves so
just to reiterate Ellen as it replaced
fellow here at NSF but from next year
she is going to be on the faculty at
University of illinois-chicago I'm here
at NSF as you heard but I'm actually
here from the University of California
in San Diego so I'm a UCSD person and I
have a couple of references to UCSD
projects and and as you heard
last week from Anita burn road ski is
also from San Diego okay so if we think
back to you know way back when
fundamentally what people were doing was
writing programs dealing with files and
that actually takes us all the way back
to sort of the beginning of computing
right so 1958 68 so their individual all
about a problem that you wanted to solve
whether it's and by the way another way
to think about the history also is how
many people were doing this and we have
where with it like it so in the early
days actually very few people doing this
kind of any kind of computing and most
of it was happening in in corporate
settings so you can think about in
corporate settings people wanting to do
inventory control or finance systems or
doing some kind of computational
computing something related to whether
they were modeling a physical process or
whatever every activity started with you
you're having to write essentially and
have initio program and the program had
to deal with its own data and now that
person moved into a setting where yeah
that's pretty moved into a setting where
you know there was plenty of data and
you have to deal with somehow making it
more efficient so from literally flat
files of data people invented new ways
of getting more efficient access to data
that what we call structured files and
and you move forward to the 60s and 70s
where we have programming languages like
l1 COBOL things that actually some of
those are probably still running
you know old systems but basically there
was a world where you were dealing with
fairly slow hardware and then discs were
much slower than memory today tests are
still slower but there's a much much
more fine hierarchy of storage between
distant memory in those days it was
pretty simple it is either a disk or a
memory and so you have to
do something to bridge across that and
so then we come to a situation where we
have therefore application logic so
remember that anything that you wanted
to do the data you will have to write a
different program right so you have the
so called application logic it's encoded
in those programs and those programs
also hardware the data that they are
going after but and the kind of models
that the situation that people found
themselves in was that multiple
different programs we're creating the
same data over and over again so if you
had you might have multiple applications
in corporate contexts that are all
dealing with employees for one reason or
the other maybe one is payroll the other
with benefits and they were all
recreating this employee information so
the realization came that you know we
are having inconsistent data and we have
duplicating they're unnecessarily so
that sort of the start of thinking about
data as something separate from the
application that's working on the data
and that's a very important concept in
computer science is the abstraction
concept that begins to separate
application logic from the data if we
think of it very easily that there's a
bit of things I can go and write sequel
queries and get all sorts of ad hoc
information out of a database that was
not the case before where the
application was very tightly tied to the
kind of data it was dealing with and
multiple applications created the same
data because there was really no sharing
going on the reason I'm happening on
that is you know some of this may come
back to us and some of the present world
might look like that but you know that's
where we came from and we realized that
we should separate those out and there
were these models called hierarchical
and network model so hierarchy is the
most obvious way you can think about
organizing information you have a
corporation you have departments you
have people working in the partner yes
that sounds hierarchical or you know you
have a human humans have different
organs and and then you can organize the
human system as a bunch of different
organ systems and that sounds like
but soon what happens is you might say
or think about courses right so you have
courses and in a university courses have
offerings so I offer of course this fall
next spring etc each offering has
students but what if you wanted to ask a
question that says for each student tell
me all the teachers that are interacting
with that student that becomes a very
difficult query to answer if it's
hierarchical in nature because they're
the sort of go up the hierarchy find out
for each person who is the which course
they are in and then for that course
who's the teacher so when people found
this kind of that there are
inefficiencies here the network model
was created which would say well maybe
for each student I should just make
pointers to all the features if I'm
asking this very very often about which
student which know what is the set of
teachers teaching the student but if you
as you think about more and more such so
queries that you want to do the the
structure becomes very complicated so
that led to the need for people to think
about what is a more abstract way in
which we can represent this information
so that any query more or less could be
equally well answered and not just stuff
there are hard-coded into the database
right and that leads to this model that
we now have is the relational model
where we say let's for all information
in tables and there is some theory
behind you know how we develop these
tables and how we make whether it be not
repeating information so we removed
replication we increase the consistency
of the database and that's our
relational databases and that's when we
realize that the notion of a database
now in computer science then is that
there is something called a data model
which is a formal definition of how data
is represented and then there is
actually a formal query language that we
can build so really this is a kind of
set oriented data models there are
relations there are dependencies among
columns in a relation and between
relations and then we can define it
formal algebra which ends up being
embodied in C
and also by then the kinds of things we
were doing with data where of two types
one was what you call transactions again
this is in the corporate context where
data is coming in there is being updated
you might be doing purchases you might
be at a bank you're doing bank
transactions so there's a whole set of
technologies related to transaction
processing they're essentially doing
insertions deletions updates on data and
then there's a whole set of things about
doing queries and remember in the old
days it was about writing you know for
each query you want it to do it
literally you have to write a program so
the technologies was what can we do
common technology that can support both
so transaction processing was very
processing and I would say from around
the 1980s onward and the relational
model came up they here was this used
one system to do it all now as we
progressed so and which was ended up
being a success relational model when it
started was not viewed as that it might
be successful there all sorts of issues
because it was in a way slow to be again
that compared to existing technologies
but a lot of work was done to make it
more efficient and as it became
successful it became the thing that
everybody wanted to use to store data so
then you got into this problems where
people said as you heard earlier that
the data was getting more complex people
wanted to store more things like images
or strings or even videos so people
would restore objects there were more
than what a standard database would
support typical database might support
your basic data types like integers
I apologize there's some interruption
doing here okay I think I'm back so the
question was how do you support objects
in this and as we moved to the 90s we
were also talking about more
object-oriented programming so objects
in C++ and Java and the other was the
need to support say things like text
video images and this is the start of
the first time we start seeing this
notion of varieties in this case it's a
variety of different objects were not
stored in the same database and this is
because the success by then of the
relational model meant that everybody
wanted to use that as the one-stop shops
for data management well in is starts
putting stress on the technology right
so as we move forward from there we also
get to the place where we are putting
more and more data in these systems and
more and more people are using remember
we started by saying there were not that
many people actually using computing and
of course by the 80s and 90s this is all
over the place so there's a lot more
data that's being generated that has to
be managed and the question was you know
how do we build efficient systems to do
that so by the mid 90s we had so-called
peril and database systems and these
were still using the relational model
still supporting SQL which is very
popular by then but then providing ways
of processing all that in parallel and
there's a big sort of industry around
that to support big clusters and
parallel computing on SQL databases well
then we come to the situation where
especially the internet web scale
companies like the googles and Facebooks
have arrived on the scene and they are
seeing even more data right so this this
is the even more volume problem and
actually along with that also goes sort
of the speed at which the data is
arriving
there is also a problem of sort of
streams and a lot of what we called the
velocity and in a way I don't know if
you can call it abandoned but those
companies realized that the relational
technology just had built up over the
years over the decades was a little bit
complicated to use for these extremely
large divide it does take a while to put
your data in the structure in and out
and also in these cases the data was not
structured it had this sort of semi
structured a characteristic word because
a lot of it was social media data coming
in through websites or web log data
which was not well structured so that
brings us systems like Hadoop which are
massively parallel massively and very
robust for the level of parallelism they
have so it literally you're talking
about thousands of nodes of computers
running and there's a robustness across
across it because in some sense you can
say that it was a very simple model that
was implemented that ensured that the
overall system was very robust okay and
that's enhanced by the fact that
hardware was relatively cheap and we had
to really literally deal with petabytes
of data that we are now seeing in many
different domains that also meant that
the implementations had to be simpler
you couldn't support the real complexity
that SQL had agglomerate it by then I
mean by this time SQL is almost like a
full programming language you couldn't
really implement all of that on massive
terabyte system so all of a sudden the
language became simpler and so he
started hearing but things like no
sequel which was meant to be simple
sequel in the beginning and now people
call it all sorts of different things
including not only sequel because
interesting trend that's happening that
has happened already in the Hadoop
massively parallel systems is SQL is
coming back right people are now
implementing more and more of SQL on top
of the system so this is we're back to
the future a kind of feeling comes back
and that's why we wanted to take you
history has to know make sense of all
the stuff that's going on so we started
with simple query languages no sequel
because people realize that even those
petabyte systems there are some very
basic things you should be able to do
like filtering data out doing simple
aggregations what in SQL you might call
group by making aggregates on certain
attribute values maybe maybe a date
value maybe the name of a person
whatever it is so simple aggregation is
very important and that brings you back
into this world of having some sort of
query language on top at the same time
there's all this essentially
unstructured stuff going on that Elena
mentioned there and and things like JSON
become very popular and all the web
stuff becomes popular so people want to
take things that they are creating in
their programming languages and dump it
straight into there so these systems
have been required to support things
like JSON now as a data model so you
have databases like Cassandra and also
all of those of many of those and no
sequel databases are going into that
semi structured mode and not the full
necessarily the full relational model
now relational model has not gone away
so this is where your menu of options
increase so you still have the
relational model you have pure Hadoop if
you want really or you could have SQL on
top of Hadoop or you could have JSON so
this is where all the choices keep
increasing and finally I think where we
are right now is if you are looking at
it from a corporate point of view and
also increasingly as individual
scientists as we are solving more
complex problems we want to deal with
many sources of data it's not just
necessarily there's really a whole group
of problems including maybe in things
like next-generation sequencing and so
on where there is one data type maybe
it's the genome sequence or it's the
social media interaction graph that you
are trying to mine and learn more from
what maybe it's just videos but there
are also now increasing more problems
where you want to put multiple different
data sets together maybe on put sensors
together with electron
cult record etc and that brings us to
this world of very heterogeneous data
sources and one concept that has now
emerged is this notion of a data Lake
and it's a little bit more about that
but essentially it's the idea that you
can dump all sorts of different data
into one place it's loosely structured
and that's the sort of analogy it will
take but at least it's all in one place
and you can do something with it
okay so that's the full circles we have
come around if you remember we started
in the 50s and 60s and here we are now
so you want to say a little bit more
what about some of these concepts and
where we might be going so let's talk a
little bit about this idea of data
warehouses versus data leaks so data
warehouses started probably in the late
80s to the 90s when they were you know
people had already rationalized their
data systems into relational databases
whatever so they reduced the redundancy
in data but what they did realize there
is that they were multiple different
data bases even within a large company
it could be geographic region so maybe
Europe they had a division in Europe a
division in the US or the East Coast and
West Coast had their own data or the
finance guys had one set of coherent
data sets and the sales guys had a
different set of data sets and when
people wanted to make good decision
support inside such a system they have
to bring all of these data together so
the data warehouse is really the concept
that if you want to get a more holistic
view of whatever it is that you are
looking at you do have to bring data
from different places together and that
led to this creation of the houses so
that they're aware houses started at the
time when people said oh you know what
this data are not just about
transactions the other thing to remember
there is a lot of the roots of data
management community actually do come
from industry because that's where
interestingly that's where data started
initially that the boom of data science
folks were doing their own little thing
and they were not really using this
technologies and if you come back to
today this is also where big data
started will actually back in industry
because again they were dealing they
just had the imperative to deal with the
data and they have to do something about
it right so
the nail of warehouses or the situation
where business said all this data that
we are collecting can we do something
more with it in terms of decision
support and strategy so but what they
realize that when they started putting
that together is that there was some
diversity in the way that this different
databases were being created even if it
was within one Enterprise one big
company or whatever and that led to some
heterogeneity and so when you put all of
this stuff back together and let's say
you're trying to get one common view of
your customer but there may be a
slightly different view of the customer
and the finance database in the slightly
different view in the sales database
this is where you have to start
generating metadata to say things like
ok what we are calling a customer ID
over there is you know something else
ID over here so data warehouses are
typically associated with being heavily
cleaned up and that's way having
metadata and and there are a lot of
rules about what can get into a data
warehousing what doesn't get in so that
when you use it it's a very sort of
clean data set and if you're dealt with
any data you know that you know cleaning
up data is a big big task and you might
have to make some difficult decisions
about what goes in and what doesn't go
in the flip side of it the data lake is
kind of the opposite you put everything
in you can imagine that structuring
cleaning and putting stuff into a data
warehouse implies that there is some
time and effort involved and also
implies that there may be some delay
involved that is from the time you you
actually receive the data wherever you
might have got it in your operational
system can the time it gets into a data
warehouse there's a delay there for you
when you're querying your warehouse you
may not be getting the latest greatest
data that the corporation might have
well so lakes were trying out trying to
solve that problem to say no there are
some applications where I just need the
latest data even if it's dirty I'm going
to deal with it so it remembers back you
may be back to the situation where you
might be writing individual applications
that are working with the daily leg but
you're having to do it just because you
want to get the
and status and you're not happy with
something that support order so that's
kind of the difference between these two
environments data warehouses provide you
single consistent store of data but they
require you to transform and ingest the
data into a warehouse there's an notion
of a star schema this image just shows
you that you know you're getting data
from different sources there is some
step of so called integration you have
to do which is all the cleaning up and
the rationalization before you can put
into a warehouse so there is work
involved there but then it enables sort
of different applications the notion of
a star schema is the reason you create
data warehouses as I said this in order
to get this holistic view it's the
holistic view of some entity that you
care about so typically it could be a
customer if you are a company or it
could be a patient it could be an
individual if you are dealing with
health care or Public Health right so
that thing that you care about is sort
of refer to as the fact and that and
that fact has many dimensions associated
with it so that's this idea of a star so
for example we might care about a person
and person's health and well-being and a
person might have different dimensions
like their you know sickness record
which is essentially the electronic
health record every time they got sick
there is some entry in the EHR but you
could also have something about their
activity their food habit where have
they travel what's their family
information so those would all be the
dimensions and to push on that analogy a
little further there is also this notion
of a snowflake schema there is each of
those dimensions itself might have a
little bit of a structure but these are
the kind of things that we deal with
when we talk about a data warehouse I
won't go too much into this slide but it
sort of repeats what I said before there
are governance issues involved
governance by the way is is a word
that's coming back today in today's
data-driven world as people realize that
they really want to use data to make
decisions whether it's
serious scientific discovery or a
corporation making some strategic
decisions and governance then is
important because he needs to know
things like provenance you need to know
where did this data come from what did
we do with this data so just as an aside
the federal government has started
something called the it's actually
called the federal data cap net
embarrass it's a collection of all the
chief data officer across federal
agencies and now there are about hundred
and twenty-five also people in that
group and I sit in on that just
representing NSF and one of the first
things first groups they started was a
group that was gonna look at governance
and you know you're first stepping down
and sister figure of what are the data
assets that we have and your next step
is to say well what can we say about the
quality of these assets right so they
did a leguminous is an important thing
and we're how those really do focus on
all of that but they are not good for
unstructured data there is latency
between when the data comes into an
organization and when it gets into a
data warehouse for all the reasons we
just mentioned so data lakes in a sense
are trying to address that and there a
lake is a new relatively new concept
it's a relatively new thing depending on
who you talk to people will either say
well that's a very important thing or
others will say this is a waste of time
or this is a just revisiting other stuff
and there's now the word there are swamp
which refers to if you put all sorts of
data into one place you know is it
really useful we're just creating a
swamp of data so there are all these
issues but the problem is really the way
and a lot of these data lakes are built
on top of this technology which is a
highly scalable technology because the
point of data lakes is you throw all
your data into it and you want doing
some easy analytics and as you heard
before a lot of the analytics may be
going after unstructured they may not be
in relational databases you may actually
be writing a program or a script of some
sort that wants to deal with relatively
unstructured flat flat files really and
so it's back to the flat file world and
the layer
support that okay so the data lakes are
increasingly also going towards this
notion of you know some structuring of
data within the lake and some of the
ideas you will see there corporations
are embracing there is this notion of a
pipe so your data may come and land in
some landing zone where it's all non
clean whatever data you collected and
there may be a sequence of steps that it
goes through and that creates the sort
of workflow process that's actually a
useful thing because then you might have
different applications that might say
you know what I'm willing to go after
the dirty dangerous data or another
application might say I'm going to go
after data in stage three after this
cleaning has been done so at least it
creates that opportunity rather than
having to say well you can't do anything
at the data so so there are some
positives to it but you know you have to
be a little bit careful in how you are
creating these these kinds of assets so
now let me flip to a project turns out
it's it's a project at UC San Diego that
that I've been involved in and not so
much involved in lewiston itself and
it's actually led by our fearless leader
there is Kevin Patrick who is in
population and public health at UC San
Diego
there are other so almost half the team
is from the med school they have kept
Chan who's actually the head it's the
beacon project in San Diego for those of
you who know about the beacon initiative
we're just trying to integrate data from
all sorts of different EHR other systems
Luciano Machado is our bioinformatics
person but the other half of the project
is computer scientists so Yanis and
Sanjay and so on our professors intro
science and the idea that we had here
was in a sense this I know what
warehouses and lakes are trying to do
that is in order to look at the whole
information related individual
the health information you need to put
together data from different sources and
of course there are many projects that
they'll have that have been doing it are
doing it and we continue to do it
already and this project was can we try
to standardize some of this so that we
don't have to repeat the same thing
again and again a lot of people do the
same thing in try and put together maybe
activity data with EHR data with
pollution data let's try to see if we
can make common api's common processes
so that so that's basically the idea and
we came up with this notion of a whole
health information model and an API to
facilitate that and I just wanted to
mention that because this is a classic
example of trying to integrate very
heterogeneous data it has
semi-structured forces in there it has
structured sources in there I don't
think initially we were going after any
text or unstructured or even with you
but you know that might be all the
things you might put in there what it is
trying to do is integrate information
from very different layers so it's not
as Kevin likes to point out it's not
about just integrating information
inside a hospital or inside a clinical
setting
it's actually about integrating all the
health information related to a person
some of which may be from a hospital but
a lot of it has to do with behavioral
and environmental and if you really
think in terms of the whole health
that's in some ways could be a lot more
important than just sort of your disease
and sickness record so anyway that's
sort of the goal of that project and so
keeping back to the kinds of data that
we'll encounter as Eleanor said before
we are not going to get into the details
but we're trying to give you a sort of
survey of things so coming back to this
notion of structured semi-structured and
so-called unstructured what do we mean
by that from a computer science point of
view I said that earlier already we
think of a database is something that's
structured as the notion of a data model
it's a formal specification of the data
and a query language that allows you to
query that actually another important
thing that relational databases do
this notion of integrating constraints
and they are very important in order to
make sure that your data is clean right
so and a simple integrity constraint
would be that social security number is
a unique number you can have to build
people with the same social security
number another constraint could be that
if somebody is working in a department
the name of that that department should
exist right she's going to be working in
a department that doesn't exist so that
led to a set of characteristics that are
associated with structured databases
refer to as acid atomicity consistency
isolation durability these are all
essentially transaction properties that
make sure that everything you do with
the database results in the correct
state of the database that you can't do
transactions and queries on the database
and mess up the database and so the
database and sure that that doesn't
happen
won't go into the details of each of
those technical things but that's an
important concept because we are back to
this sort of liberal Wild West world as
we said before with no sequel JSON some
of which will have this notion of
relaxed consistency you might see the
term where it's not necessarily always
true that the database is consistent and
therefore applications have to be very
careful that they may be encountering
data that's not completely clean and
again sometimes you have to read the
reason they relax those constraints is
in order to be able to deal with either
the volume of the data or the rate of
the data if you're dealing with data
that's coming in very fast you may not
just have enough time to make sure that
it's all consistent and so on so it's
useful to know that you know we're back
to the world where we're breaking some
of the rules that we had before so you
know in structured databases everything
looks very regular like in a relational
database all rows have the same format
some a struct databases as mentioned an
example would be XML and they tend they
allow for a little bit actually for ad
hoc structures so if you think about a
bibliography at the end of an article
would have all sorts of things in it
like papers
and all sort of other things and each of
those might have a slightly different
structure and you may not want to bend
over backwards and try to put all of
them into a relational database a semi
structured model makes a lot of sense
they're a lot of webpages have that kind
of structure right unis the content in
the webpage nowadays may come from a
database of some sort the overall
structure itself may be better
represented as a semi structured so I
won't go into the syntax details etc
just quickly some of the trends where we
are going it turns out as we represent
more and more complex information
whether it's a cellular interaction and
sort of human interactions graphs are a
very important type of data and now on
the technology side people have
beginning to build systems that
efficiently support graph data so one of
the things we do the draft is still
useful to be able to query a graph right
so you can say get me all the nodes in
this graph that have certain properties
but other things you do the graphs are
traversing the graph what we might want
to find the shortest path between X and
y and the path might represent some say
connections between cells in the brain
when enough people who you heard about
the neuroscience information facility
last time they do a lot of those kinds
of things graphs may also represent
semantic linkages what we call our
ontology x' between terms so the lot of
cases where graphs turn up and graph
data is increasingly very important kind
of data might end up dominating big
parts of some of the applications that's
a graph of actually my LinkedIn network
and we are also moving towards this
notion of creating knowledge graphs so
that we can build in the semantics and
understand the meanings of the terms
that we are referring to and the
relationships between them and I think
we have heard about these concepts and
some of the other talks and probably
will hear more this is clearly you know
if there is something called semantic
pubmed where people are trying to
extract the semantics of the articles
and make those connections between
articles based on the meaning of the
stuff rather than just specific words
another trend that's rapidly approaching
and my own views and future everything
will think of everything as a stream
except some streams will be much slower
than others it is bitter streams and
that's because the rate at which data is
coming at us regardless of what the
source of data is it's just growing more
and more
everything starts looking like just a
sequence of stuff and examples right now
are things like log files on a computer
ecommerce which is this click streams
now when you're clicking on a website
game information information from social
networks Twitter tweets look around
screens and so on there's a lot of this
going on and there are new technologies
that are being developed one of the ones
this is just one example is from Amazon
called Kinesis that allows you to sort
of capture this stream of stuff coming
in and here the example is mobile phones
but the project that I've been working
on with Kevin Patrick actually there are
a couple of other projects that I didn't
mention involving MD Anderson Cancer
Center is where we are putting sensors
on people you know whether it's
smartphones or other kinds of sensors
and measuring various body parameters
and those are all coming in as streams
and there's going to be more and more of
that
I'm sure familiar with and then at the
end of it that data could go into all
sorts of different storage and that sort
s3 redshift Amazon Elastic surge are all
again different ways of storing this so
like we said before your menu of options
are many right now so finally some
take-home messages so when you are
looking at the data each of us as
individuals might be focused on one
aspect of it but really every piece of
data has a life cycle and increasingly
if you have to worry about it you know
how was it collected where did it come
from
and where is it going to end up and
people are very concerned nowadays that
you know especially in academia we think
of a paper as the ultimate goal the
ultimate goal really should be the data
that's related with the paper and where
does the data end up so until that data
hasn't lit up somewhere safely
shouldn't say that your work is not just
publishing a paper shouldn't be the end
of it performance I mean speaking as
computer people and and I know I need to
mentioned something about this last time
that computer scientists cared a lot
about performance yes we do making
things go fast that's what I mean and
actually going fast can be a
game-changer right just think about it
if every little data step that you had
to do took whatever they will completely
change how you do your data analysis if
things go very fast it's a big enabler
so we are all computer science is always
focus now to make it go faster and
faster other take-home messages in the
data in the world of data science there
are a lot of different problems and
really goes back to the Left lifecycle
question is everything from cleaning to
prediction and there are all these tools
you can use along along the way so
increasingly you know you're in an
environment where you can actually use
the right data management tool for the
right job
it just means you need to have some
awareness of what is available but also
what might you be giving up if you pick
one option versus the other so what is
it by right and finally offer there is a
context issue maybe it's you know it's
it's something you're just doing by
yourself you're doing it in the lab and
institution context may be a community
which which may either give you more
options or may restrict what you can do
so that's that's just sort of the big
picture the last thing I want to say is
something that we've been looking yet
here at the world of data science so if
you think about or the agenda of data as
it's going to grow into the future data
is going to be more and more important
to us everywhere in our lives right and
there's going to be a lot of decisions
where the we make them or some automated
device or a robot makes them will all be
data-driven so here I'm starting with an
example of this computer science our own
discipline in computer science itself
there are areas in CS that are becoming
more data intensive so there is more and
more data available to do research in
computer science an example would be
Internet traffic there's a whole network
research community income
the science that research is Internet
traffic and tries to understand what's
going on on the Internet by looking at
their traffic the amount of traffic is
just tremendously growing obviously
another one is data center logs you know
increasingly we have these massive data
centers with lots of computers and you
can actually look at the logs that have
all sorts of information about the
performance the temperature etc and
actually you can use there to optimize
energy consumption and all sorts of
other things so there is an example just
in computer science of data coming at us
and us having to deal with it to do
better computer science research now we
happen to think that data of science and
actually engineering which is a very
important part related to data now is a
thing unto itself I mean it's it's
almost like a discipline to itself is
data science and engineering which has
its own theories and a set for example
just release the solicitation for
developing the principles of data
science and there are issues like data
representation and we mentioned some of
that today modeling whether it's
statistical modeling or representation
modeling machine learning decision
support reproducibility I think this all
of those together form the sort of
discipline of data science in
engineering and our idea is that there
is a translational aspect which is the
aspect of taking all these principles
and theories of data science and
applying it to real world problems okay
and that application there is some
analogy to this notion of translational
medicine there you're talking about
taking research results and applying it
in the clinical context really what all
of us many of us it is to do with data
is its clinical context of data right we
are using data in the real world and we
are thinking what techniques should I
use on that data that's translational
stuff and so there obviously there are
intensive everything going on whether
it's biology science medicine and so on
so we see an opportunity here to think
about sort of a lot of what's actually
being done there is really translational
work and pursue that idea a little bit
here in SF and and I think that's that's
it there's there's a few more minutes
for questions great thank you so much
coffee experience
sylia that is a great talk so we have
one question from the audience at this
point which is about the data lake in
the data warehouse so the question is
can data bleep put into the data lake
and into the data warehouse at the same
time as it's being prepared for the data
warehouse and can you comment a little
bit about about that sort of potential
parallel sort of framework yes there's a
good question and in a sense the answer
I guess is a qualified yes only in the
sense that like I said the data
warehouse is definitely very very
prescriptive right things can go into
the data warehouse unless they need a
certain set of conditions that that sort
of the notion of a warehouse as we said
a lake you could more or less dump
anything in there but we also said that
in a data Lake people are now beginning
to actually talk about phases of the
data so the data could go through
multiple phases of structuring and
cleaning so it could be that at some
point in that process the data has
reached the level of cleanliness let's
say that your data warehouse would say
okay I can accept that
and then you would do it and the reason
to do it is data warehousing by the way
is a big industry so a lot of good tools
and varying tools
analysis tools as well as visualization
tools for your data so you may want to
actually use all of those things whereas
data Lake is still a little bit out
there in the Wild West right now so that
might be a reason why you want to do
both yeah okay so another question is
often time when we're designing these
types of databases the queries
themselves are not necessarily known
ahead of time and often we want to
design these databases in order to sort
of optimize the query response but
without knowing the queries or if we're
trying to support sort of an exploratory
set of data and inquiries in in that
nature
it's very difficult to know ahead of
time which type of database help we
should be using what type of data schema
we should be using
are there any approaches for instance
that take a hybrid approach where data
actually goes into multiple different
types of databases simultaneously
actually I love the excellent questions
okay so their first times I want to give
you they're actually something I didn't
cover maybe I should have maybe we can
do it in future is this notion of poly
stores use it's still I would say more
in the computer science community it's a
polyethylene pol Y store and funny story
ideas exactly what you're saying where
people are people are realizing that you
know here's an application that I am
interested in but this application has
different kinds of data they're all
related to that application and the
different guidance could mean some of it
is structured in word structure other of
it is I'm not quite sure what the
structure is but another piece of it may
be a graph I actually derive so I might
imagine this situation I might have text
and I might process the text to derive
certain a graph out of it maybe it's a
graph of all the people in that text and
the connections among the people but I
want to keep both I want people I want
to keep the text office but I also want
to keep the derive graph of it so the
graph might actually go into a graph
database the text might just stay in
some system that does indexing of the
text and you might also have structures
so in computer science and there are
some startup companies I'm aware of that
are now beginning to do this kind of
thing saying let's invent a poly store
and in a way try to take the
responsibility from the user and put it
in the system so the user right now I
don't think that part is there yet right
now the user still has to say but this
is a graph and that's this X and this is
that and I want you to manage all of
these but people are also looking at
things like maybe the same data could be
in multiple representations also maybe
the system can decide at what point can
it go from one to the other but until
that happens I mean sure them so that's
one technology that's coming you might
want to look for it
but the other way to do it is actually
to use the semi-structured and all I've
heard is you know just look out I think
you'll find increasingly more vendors
providing more support for semi
structured data so in a in a semi
structured well you can certainly have a
structure power of it you can just say
well that part of it is fixed right and
this other part is variable so you could
use a semi structured model to do that
okay so I think we have one time for one
more question which is so one of the
interesting things in at least in the
biomedical spaces and is about
scientific reproducibility and could you
speak to the provenance of the data in
particularly in terms of the
translational data processes that a
database may support yes and I actually
think there's a lot of work has gone on
solving computer science research about
this notion of provenance by the way you
know I think there are even watch at
least workshop I don't think conferences
that I've talked about prominence big
data that is you can imagine now that
you know not only do you have this
little itty-bitty piece of data that you
care about but if we kept all its
provenance the provenance can be huge
compared to the data that you have
so people are already starting to worry
about what's the explosion that's going
to happen in the amount of day if I
start keeping the prominence of it what
we don't have yet I believe is good
systems and software systems or products
that do a good job I mean there are
certainly products that are trying to
help in that way I don't think it's zero
well I think that that part of it is
just beginning to happen so I think
something a lot more systematic and in
software systems need to be available so
that every one of us could be using
using this and you know using provenance
without there
I'm just big name I'm just thinking
about it but in the computer science
world there is a lot of research here's
one example so even when you run an SQL
query very database the school is
structured language you get a result
back and for those of you who are
familiar with SQL so you have joins
write submit have lots of joints going
on and things like this and you're gonna
result back and a lot of times you might
want to say what how did this particular
row up here in this result said I wasn't
expecting it so people are actually
looking at actually the prominence of
individual rows in the query of a
relational database which is actually
itself turns out to be quite an
interesting challenging problem that
user should be able to click on a row
and say tell me how this came in right
and the system should be able to say
well this came in because I joined that
with this and we selected this one over
there and this lands up here so these
are all beginning to happen and it's
just going to be even more even more
data and and and also there's the recent
paper somebody just sent me about why
all of this is actually random they can
make a big computational ok so I think
we're out of time so thank you again so
much for this wonderful talk we're
getting a lot of positive feedback
already from from the attendees and
we'll end it here thank you
all right great thanks